the United States government has a
problem with insider trading which
basically means whenever you have
information about the stock market that
no one else has and you use it to make
big trades and you make money off of it
yeah that's insider trading and we have
all these documents that are pretty
damning we did a whole Deep dive on this
but here's just a little sampling
Republican senator Richard Burr Richard
Burr goes into a private briefing where
he is told that the economy is about to
melt down and the very next day he
shorts the market like he does the thing
where you bet that the Market's gonna go
down and guess what it does and he makes
a ton of money our list would not be
complete without former Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi who is married to an
investor they've done so well during
downturns in the US economy that there's
actually an entire community of
investors on the internet that just copy
their trades because they know that
they're going to do well and luckily all
of this stuff is public that's how we
have our hands on it we have an insider
trading problem here in the United
States like we need Congress to regulate
themselves and that probably won't ever
happen